Alright, it's game time.
We're ready to ride a motorcycle.
I'm gonna start off just like I showed you.
I'm gonna pull this clutch in, down into first gear,...
...and now you're gonna notice me releasing the clutch and then coming on with the gas.
Boom, we're under way.
One of the things I want you to notice is how fast I picked up my foot over there.
Sometimes rookies have this instinct to keep their feet down to help keep their balance.
It can be dangerous if you have a foot come down while the bike's at speed.
So, make a conscious effort to get your feet up as soon as it's practical.
Now, I'm getting ready to come to a stop here.
So, what I'm gonna do is the reverse of what we just did.
Clutch in, throttle off, and brake smoothly to a stop.
At this point, that's it.
This is how you ride a motorcycle.